[Musique]
notre invité est capable de danser comme
Michael Jackson de chanter comme Stevie
Wonder de jouer de nous faire rire vous
le voyez comme Eddy Murphy oui il est un
concentré de tout ces talents et ça fait
plus 30 ans que ça dure en France mais
aussi au Québec où il a commencé
d'ailleurs il est l'un des premiers à
avoir importé sur la scène française le
show à la nord-américaine ces spectacles
où on en prend plein les yeux mais il y
a quelques temps il a ajouté une corde à
son arc un nouveau talon celui de nous
aider à être heureux happy comme le dit
le titre de son spectacle à la gaieté
Montparnasse nous rendre heureux il le
fait le temps du chaud mais pas
seulement c'est devenu pour lui une
vraie philosophie de vie il a même fait
plusieurs formations il est devenu coach
en PNL programmation neuro-linguistique
oulala je vous entends d'ici vous
demandez de quoi il s'agit vous demandez
si ce n'est pas une sombre technique de
développement personnel où vous risquez
de tomber sur un gourou et bien posons
lui ces questions bienvenue dans un
monde à bienvenue Anthony Kavanagh merci
d'être avec nous et de déjà commencer à
faire le show sur ce plateau nous sommes
dans le dôme Tournon du Sénat vous savez
comme les Français sont méfiants
cartésiens interrogateur disons le
franchement quand on entend PNL on se
méfie en France c'est ça que vous
vouliez dire
la glace il a dit casse-couille au Sénat
hérétique sortait d'ici cette
programmation neurolinguistique vous
êtes devenu coach c'est un vrai sujet
c'est une vraie science c'est une vraie
matière
je veux dire il y en a qui disent que
c'est une pseudo science et c'est tant
mieux et c'est tant mieux
la PNL qu'est-ce que c'est c'est l'art
de la communication avec soi-même et les
autres
en PNL on apprend à se reprogrammer ou
ce programmer en utilisant nos cinq sens
le système le système nerveux et le
langage
en PNL on ét c'est ce qu'on appelle les
comportements à succès on prend
quelqu'un qui a réussi dans un domaine
on décortique sa recette et on l'a
modélise comme ça on va arriver plus
rapidement au même résultat si tu fais
la même chose que cette personne si tu
fais exactement ce qu'elle a fait pour y
arriver donc tu évites les erreurs qu'il
y a la commises tu prends tout ce
qu'elle a fait de bien tu vas arriver au
même résultat en moins de temps cette
personne a pris 20 ans pour y arriver
mais avec sa recette toi tu vas
peut-être ça va peut-être te prendre 5
ans pour y arriver qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui critiquent cela en
disant qu'il y a pas de recette pour le
bonheur que en fait c'est un business un
business très florissant qui arrange les
coachs ou qui est même un risque de
secte mais ce n'est la PNL ne se vend
pas comme étant la recette du bonheur ça
fonctionne
moi j'ai décidé d'étudier ce que les
gens heureux faisaient pour être rapide
de modéliser les gens heureux pour le
spectacle de manière générale vous êtes
quand même fasciné depuis toujours par
l'être humain par le fonctionnement du
cerveau de l'inconscient des émotions
l'observation de l'humain est d'ailleurs
très présente dans votre spectacle dans
ce spectacle happy est-ce que vous avez
eu l'impression que les Français avaient
besoin d'une cure
l'être humain a besoin d'une cure les
humoristes sont des observateurs de
l'humain c'est notre boulot on est un
humoriste c'est un miroir placé selon
son point de vue de la société actuelle
voilà
je dis toujours que si tu prends les 20
meilleurs comiques de l'époque et si tu
regardes tout le roi le même show tu vas
avoir une image en instant T de la
société ou tu vis est-ce que est-ce que
l'économie va bien est-ce que est-ce
qu'on aime le gouvernement on aime le ce
qu'on aime le président est-ce que ce
qu'il y a il y a des soucis dans les
relations homme-femmes est-ce que on va
on va tout avoir un portrait
d'humoriste en France qui à succès en
tout cas qu'est-ce que vous diriez sur
la France sur l'état de la France
je ne les ai pas tous vu il y a
la France la France est
la France est stressée en ce moment la
France quand je suis revenu en France
après covid je trouvais que les
Parisiens avaient changé je l'ai trouvé
moins moins agressif
tant mieux donc quand je suis revenu il
y a deux ans
presque deux ans j'ai trouvé moins
agressif j'ai trouvé plus plus patient
plus
bon un peu moins maintenant
le naturel revient au galop mais je
trouve quand même qu'on est un cran en
dessous ensuite le stress ça ça ne
change pas on stresse la population
française tout le temps que ce soit à la
radio que ce soit à la télé en utilisant
en utilisant des mots toujours trop
forts la crise c'est toujours la
réception la carte c'est toujours la
catastrophe c'est toujours les mots qui
l'inconscient fait il a pas de seconde
degré il y en a conscient tu dis
catastrophe une catastrophe c'est c'est
la fin du monde ça a l'air donc que des
mots
on le fait moins on le fait moins on
utilise les mots un peu plus un petit
peu plus doux on stresse quand même le
stress quand même les gens
parce que quand tu stresses les gens
c'est plus facile de leur vendre des
produits après quand tu veux quand même
sur votre histoire personnelle
votre famille de vendre des choses de
vendre des choses quand tu stresses les
gens je suis stressé mon cortex répond
préfrontal c'est un tout mon sang va
dans les extrémité ce qui se passe vite
je te passe un petit message d'un
produit X ou Y et ça rentre ça rentre
dans le continent je vais aller jeter
cette merde demain
revenons un peu si vous le voulez bien
sur votre histoire personnelle votre
famille est originaire d'Haïti vous
grandissez dans la banlieue de Montréal
vous avez un père enseignant une mère
directrice d'hôpital vous dites que tout
le monde dans votre famille a une
maîtrise ou un doctorat vous vous avez
quitté l'université au bout de 6 mois ce
qui a paniqué votre père beaucoup moins
votre mère qui a eu plus confiance le
déclencheur de votre amour pour la scène
c'est un spectacle à l'école vous avez
14 ans vous faites un carton devant 400
personnes une révélation est-ce que
c'est parce que justement vous vous
rendez compte que vous apportez du
bonheur aux gens et on y revient ah oui
complètement
c'était extraordinaire de sentir ça de
voir les gens qui d'entendre tous ces
rires super waouh c'est moi qui fait ça
c'est rire et je suis sorti c'était
c'était il y avait plus d'autres choix
c'est ce que j'allais faire dans ma vie
j'ai dit je vais faire rire les gens et
j'avais 14 ans c'était décidé à 16 ans
je faisais déjà mon plan de carrière de
qui je vais faire ça je vais faire ça
et personne rien ni personne ne pouvait
m'arrêter et elle a lueur de celui que
vous êtes aujourd'hui quel conseil
donneriez-vous au petit garçon qui se
lance dans la vie ou au jeune homme
maintenant vous connaissez la suite
fait moins confiance
fais-moi confiance à certaines personnes
protège-toi un petit peu plus c'est
surtout ça c'est surtout
des cerveaux droits entourés de cerveaux
gauche quand il y a de l'argent voilà il
y a de l'argent ça change ça change tout
la carrière en France vous dites que
c'est un bel accident vous rêviez plus
des États-Unis que de l'Europe mais vous
aimiez quand même certains humoristes
français je pense aux inconnus à ailier
Dieudonné et c'est Pascal Légitimus qui
vous permet de vous lancer il organise
un showcase il invite plein de
producteurs tout un parterre de
producteurs sa mort pas vraiment sauf un
seul il y en a un qui va mordre à l'abso
à l'hameçon il suffira d'un seul pour
que votre carrière se lance en France
effectivement Pascal on passe qu'à les
moins c'est on était jumelés à Montreux
au festival du mont de Montreux par le
programmateur de l'époque qui s'appelle
Max cerveau qui était programmateur a
juste pour rire et à Montreux donc lui
il m'avait vu plusieurs fois puis il a
dit toi ça passerait vraiment bien en
Europe donc il m'invite une première
année j'y vais en dilettante
l'Europe m'intéresse pas mais je vais y
aller c'est génial ce métier tu peux
voyager
carton révélation de festival je fais
waouh ok l'année d'après il dit je vais
être jumeler avec un mec je suis sûr que
ça va bien se passer parce qu'à
Légitimus waouh les Inconnus Je
connaissais bien connu en fait deux
numéros ensemble à Montréal et à mon
truc carton je fais mon choix mon truc
attends et là Pascal
discute avec moi moi je vois qu'il y a
une place pour moi je dis il y a une
niche en Europe là pour moi il y a une
place mais Pascal était d'accord puis
elle a dit je j'aimerais t'aider à
adapter ton spectacle pour la France go
on commence à on commence à écrire je
venais une à deux fois par mois pendant
un an en France pour apprendre à
connaître les Français ça veut dire quoi
l'adapter son humour aux Français
culturel ce n'est pas universel la
musique c'est universelle l'humour c'est
culturel là tu ressens la musique tu
dois comprendre le mot
comprendre donc on doit comprendre la
langue on doit comprendre les références
on doit comprendre toutes les petites
expressions on doit tout comprendre les
codes sociaux donc il fallait adapter
tout ça et pour vous vous l'avez vite
compris cet humour français
ça m'a pris un an un an pour venir en
venant vraiment et j'ai tout misé je me
disais ma carrière au Québec je me
disais mon argent je payais mes billets
je venais je passais j'ai passé 6 mois
en France pour faire ça mais pour être
une éponge pour dire ok je vais au
théâtre je vais au cinéma je vais au
resto je marche dans la rue je vais dans
les parcs je pose des questions 24
heures sur 24 à tout le monde je veux
comprendre les Français parce que je
vais me retrouver sur scène
telle expression c'est quoi vous dites
quoi ici je voulais trouver l'équivalent
pour pour la France mais français
l'humour français il y a eu un coup de
cœur
de la France Paris qui est
on tombe amoureux de Paris mais j'ai
après c'est devenu une relation amour
haine c'est à chaque fois je suis sur le
charme de cette de cette ville il y a de
l'histoire partout regardez je suis ici
avec vous il y a de l'histoire je suis
entouré de l'éloquence la justice
la prudence et derrière moi la sagesse
donc je suis il y a de l'histoire
partout dans cette ville donc ça c'est
un réel bonheur pour moi il y a il y a
Paris et il y a certains parisiens que
j'aime moins donc
québécois pour le dire c'est un sujet
qui est un succès qui va quand même vous
emmener à l'Olympia où vous allez
célébrer vos 30 ans et vous dites
quelque chose de très joli vous dites à
l'époque c'est l'Olympia qui te
choisissait c'était le directeur du
théâtre qui t'adoubet
maintenant elle est bien c'est ouais
février
le bouquet de semaine
l'artiste de cirque avec un clown et
tout bah c'est bon
à l'époque c'était Jean-Michel Boris qui
disait toi tu mérites d'être à l'Olympia
toi toi tu pouvais être connu tu peux
être une star c'est lui tu aimais pas si
tu trouvais que tu étais pas à la
hauteur de l'Empire tu passais pas donc
je lui avais rencontré trois ans avant
et ma manageuse de l'époque le
connaissait elle me présente si
Jean-Michel Boris le directeur de
l'Olympia là je suis à Monsieur Boris
regardez-moi bien dans 3 ans je joue
dans votre théâtre ah bien sûr
bonne journée trois ans après je jouais
dans son théâtre comme comme prévu et
c'est
il était venu me voir au Trévise où je
jouais ça faisait ça faisait trois mon
dieu
quatre mois que je joue au Trévise il
est venu me voir il a fait ouais en
septembre il sera prêt
on était en plein hiver il a dit
je pense qu'on était en janvier en
septembre à ce rythme là septembre il
s'appelait donc go on va le bouquet mais
ça n'a pas toujours été si simple
humoriste et aussi un métier un gras et
solitaire parfois vous avez dit un jour
deux fois je suis monté sur scène sans
avoir un seul rire c'est gravé dans ma
peau à tout jamais dans ces moments on
se dit quoi qu'on va il faut arrêter
ça se termine
deux fois deux fois deux fois où pas un
seul rire et les deux fois ce sont des
galas privés des gars privés ou les gens
savent pas que c'est toi ou il y en a il
y en a un des deux c'est le premier
j'animais le gala j'avais bon Dieu 19 ou
20 ans et le deuxième je devais avoir
quel âge j'avais 22
c'est une drôle d'épreuve c'est très
violent très très
je me souviens c'était un tournoi de
golf au Québec il m'avait fait
ils m'ont fait attendre trois heures
trois heures de retard sur le planning
donc j'aurais pu me lever et partir je
c'était mon droit
rester je fais le truc tout le monde
mangeait devant moi donc
la table qui était devant moi c'est
tellement drôle le thé il me regardait
avec tellement de il avait pitié de moi
et ça le pauvre mais voilà on m'a engagé
pour faire une heure j'ai fait mon heure
merci au revoir je suis parti mais c'est
c'est mais ça fait partie de la vie d'un
humain ils sont doivent on doit passer
par ces moments là pour se créer une
carapace vous avez été considéré comme
un humoriste noir en arrivant en France
vous avez senti qu'il y avait un regard
particulier parce que vous étiez noir et
pas au Québec beaucoup moins au Québec
beaucoup moins Québec au Québec c'est
arrivé bien sûr aussi parce que quand
elle
le premier stand-up noir que tu arrives
oui il y a oui je l'ai au Québec comme
en France non on te mettra pas sur même
si tu as du succès on te mettra pas sur
une couverture de magasin lorsqu'on met
pas de noir sur les magazines où on a
peur que si on met un noir sur la
couverture du magazine on en vendra pas
sans me la fait ici on me l'a fait au
Québec
médecin vous avez dit mais non ça
n'existe pas
c'était un bon médecin est noir donc
c'est magnifique et donc un peu il faut
il faut justifier Anthony ta présence
[Musique]
à justifier mais si le personnage est
noir il va falloir le juste il va
falloir le justifier
et c'est pas comme si j'étais pas allé
frapper ou pas j'ai dit bon si on ne
vient pas à moi Mohamed ira à la
montagne et puis je suis allé frapper
je proposais des choses mais à chaque
fois il y avait un problème de couleur
toujours un problème de couleur
vous diriez parce qu'aujourd'hui on
pense à aussi
oui
ça évolué
Omar Sy c'était très drôle parce qu'on
puis en plus je l'avais dit ça Omar il
avait trouvé ça très drôle mais
il y a un acteur mais fait beaucoup
rigoler il y a une peut-être
deux ans après intouchables il a dit
Omar Sy mais les autres non
c'est terrible oui parce qu'à chaque
fois c'était on mentionnait
Omar comme
fini
j'avais été de nous faire chier là et
Omar Sy et voilà
une femme qui va jouer dans tous les
films bon il y a une femme qui joue vous
allez pas il y a une femme donc c'est un
peu ça mais j'ai découvert
je dois l'admettre
il y a encore un truc qui me dérange ce
sont les rôles qu'on offre au noir au
cinéma français c'est encore le mec de
banlieue c'est encore le mec qui sort de
prison sa mère elle a 8 enfants avec 8
paires
elle a
c'est ma petite phrase c'est pas c'est
pas c'est on voit rarement un jeune
jeune Noir professionnel et où un noir
où on ne parle pas du fait qu'il soit
noir une fois dans le film comme aux
États-Unis vous allez voir des des
acteurs comme Denzel comme Will Smith
comme Samuel Jackson ou des trucs comme
ça puis on mentionne pas une fois dans
le film le fait qu'il soit noir et c'est
très nord-américain aussi parce que j'ai
découvert en préparant cette émission
que le multiculturalisme était inscrit
dans la loi au Canada loi de 1985 sur je
cite le maintien et la valorisation du
multiculturalisme au Canada c'est plus
ancré la BAC ici finalement dans les
textes
multiculturalisme les Américains ont une
autre méthode
ils appellent ça le melting pot tu
rentres tu sautes dans la dans la soupe
dans le ragoût et tu vas amener ton
épice
au Rago américain
tu vas être américain et ta loi
américain tu vas être hispano-américain
tu vas être telle chose américaine mais
tu es dans les tu rentres à 6000 toi
devient américain
tandis que au Québec c'est reste garde
ta culture au Canada plutôt garde ta
culture
garde tes codes et bienvenue au Canada
ce qui
ce qui est bien et moins bien aussi il y
a qualité défaut des deux côtés moi je
me dis toujours que quand tu quand tu
viens dans un pays tu amènes
effectivement ta saveur
ta couleur mais il faut s'intégrer dans
le pays dans lequel on est c'est ce pays
qui nous accueille
quand je suis arrivé en France pendant
moi j'étais je me suis considérais
toujours comme un invité j'ai vécu 16
ans et demi en France mais j'étais je
dis je suis un invité je suis un invité
j'ai
et puis un moment donné après j'ai dit
attends ça fait 12 ans que je fais mes
impôts ici que je vais ici mon fils est
né ici j'ai dit
chez moi je suis chez moi je suis un peu
français quand même j'ai dit je viens
après après tout ça je dis je devrais
j'ai le droit de j'ai le droit de de
critiquer j'ai le droit j'ai des photos
pour vous Anthony Kavanagh
la première savez-vous de ce qu'il
s'agit
public ne saura pas mais vous peut-être
tout le temps que ma chance
de l'éducation alors non Jean-François
Robert je ministre québécois de la
langue française j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait un ministère de la langue
française au Québec il y a peut-être
autre chose avant hein mais en tout cas
ministre de la langue française et ça
m'a interpellé parce qu'on a du mal à se
rendre compte vu d'ici c'est difficile
de défendre la langue française au
Québec vous êtes un peu le village
bourgeois
nous sommes les Gaulois entourés de
360 millions de
Romains anglophones et c'est un miracle
déjà qu'on parle français encore en
Amérique au Québec et
quelques parties de quelques provinces
autres provinces canadiennes c'est un
miracle c'est un combat de tous les
jours parce qu'il y a l'influence de la
télé américaine la télé la culture
américaine et ça vous semble important à
vous comme combat ce combat pour la
langue française pour garder la langue
française oui important quelques fois ça
va un peu trop loin parce qu'on traduit
tout en France comme vous êtes dans une
position dominante
c'est la France on parle français ah
tiens il y a un mot arabe j'aime bien je
vais prendre ça un mot italien allez on
est on traduit par l'intègre un mois
américain tac on intègre
nous on les traduit sinon sinon la
langue va disparaître si on fait on fait
rentrer tous les mots anglais il y en a
déjà quand même pas mal qui sont passés
entre le filet et il y a plusieurs
Québécois qui disent ah mais les
Français parlent par l'anglais
il traduisent pas mais je leur dis mais
nous aussi on laisse passer pleinement
il y a des mots qu'on a laissé passer
depuis tellement longtemps qu'on a
oublié que ce sont des mots anglophones
on les affran francisés mais exemple
quelqu'un va dire c'est rare c'est top
Rohff entorse c'est au Québec c'est
Rohff c'est ça fit pas
c'est j'ai écouté une bonne tonne toon
c'est anglais aussi non ça fait
tellement longtemps que c'est là qu'on a
oublié que c'était un mot un mot
francophone et et d'un autre côté
comme j'ai ça aussi j'avais fait des
recherches là-dedans faut pas oublier
qu'il y a 30% de l'anglais qui vient du
français 30% et quelquefois les Anglais
nous ramènent un mot français comme
barbecue ça vient de barbe à queue on
faisait cuire la viande de la barbe à la
queue
[Musique]
oui il a finalement été acquitté mais
l'affaire a quand même été long et très
complexe ça a posé les questions des
limites qu'on donne à l'humour est-ce
que c'est une affaire qui vous a fait
peur à vous en tant que vive la Cour
suprême qui a pris la bonne décision à
la fin à la Cour de cassation ici en
France c'est quoi cassation oui ça nous
a tous inquiété parce que parce que ça
ouvre la porte après
pas mal pas mal de choses et pas mal de
restrictions possibles mais vous avez
pas le droit de parler déjà en Amérique
du Nord dans les universités il y a
beaucoup de d'humoristes connues qui ne
veulent plus jouer pour des universités
parce que surtout aux États-Unis où on
te dit mais t'as pas le droit de dire ça
tu as pas le droit de dire ça les
universités walk ou tu dis non ne dis
pas ça ne dis pas ça ne dis pas ça pas
le droit de faire des vannes sur ça ça
donc tu dis bon on y va pas vous avez
plus de sens de l'humour il y a plus de
tout le monde est soupe aux lettres tout
le monde est il y a plus de seconde
degré il c'est intéressant parce que
vous faites exactement l'inverse dans
votre spectacle vous commencez le
spectacle en disant attention je fais
appel à votre second degré à tous et
tout le monde sera logé à la même
enseigne tous le monde est prévu il faut
le faire maintenant parce que on les
gens déjà oublient que c'est un chaud
d'humour les gens oublient que quand tu
vas voir le champ du monde mais il faut
avoir le sens de l'humour et que je
déteste les gens qui rigolent des autres
mais dès qu'on se moque d'eux mais là il
trouve plus ça drôle ça insupportable la
première personne qui doit te faire rire
c'est toi tu dois te je le dis dans ce
spectacle je moquais moquez vous de
vous-même une fois que tu arrives à
permettez-moi l'expression de te [__]
de ta propre gueule il n'y a plus rien
qui peut t'atteindre si tu arrives à te
moquer de toi-même tu vois tu vois tu
vas rigoler avec tout le monde après
donc et ça marche une dernière photo
c'est vous aux NRJ Music Awards
il y a 20 ans aussi peut-être événement
musical diffusé tous les ans sur TF1
vous lui êtes présenté pendant 6 ans un
moment incroyable de votre carrière
c'est là aussi on est vraiment une star
en France très grand public à un moment
donné vous en aviez fait le tour vous
avez eu envie d'arrêter vous seriez
candidat pour y revenir ou pas vous
auriez envie de refaire
faudrait qu'on m'appelle faudrait qu'on
discute faudrait que j'ai de la place
faudrait que j'ai le temps
le temps il y a beau il y a plein de
choses c'est mon pote Nikos qui est le
bébé de mon pote Nikos sur medies
j'arrête
j'en ai marre vas-y comme moi à l'époque
je dis je leur avais dit engagé Nikos en
premier ça leur a pris trois ans
ils ont engagé d'autres gens mais
j'avais déjà engagé engagé une cause
donc la troisième année ils l'ont engagé
voilà faudra qu'on me laisse un peu de
place
même à l'époque c'était pas toujours
évident au niveau des textes
non tu as pas le droit de dire ça tu as
pas le droit quelquefois
je laissais passer des choses que je
savais que j'allais dire mais que je
m'étais pas dans le texte le texte qui
était proposé au directeur de la chaîne
c'est sorti c'est de l'impro
une dernière question qui est en lien
avec le lieu dans lequel nous sommes
Anthony Kavanagh vous les avez remarqué
ces statues qui représentent chacune une
vertu vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il
y a la sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence est-ce qu'il y a une de ces
j'allais dire une de ses sagesse non une
de ses vertus qui vous caractérise
aujourd'hui le Anthony Kavanagh
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Musique]